[Music]
Steve Jobs turned Apple into one of the
biggest companies in the world
so when he passed away in 2011 people
wondered what will this mean for Apple
this is my first product launch since
being named CEO I'm sure you didn't know
that
when Tim Cook took the stage in June
2011 for a special event to introduce a
new iPhone a seat was reserved in the
front for jobs in case he was feeling
well enough to attend but diagnosed with
pancreatic cancer jobs health had
worsened the following day he died at
the age of 56.
Apple's chief designer Johnny Ive
skipped the event to be at Job side as
told in the book after Steve by Wall
Street Journal correspondent Tripp
Mickel jobs considered Ive the second
most important person at Apple after
himself hey Johnny
we had lunch together nearly every day a
typical conversation would go like this
hey Johnny
is a Dopey idea
and sometimes they were
jobs gave IV the freedom for his
creative juices to flow
I've was inspired by The Godfather of
design Dita Ramsay's philosophy of
creating simple and functional products
yet after Jobs died Apple appeared to
shift its focus from design to
prioritizing profit cook made Apple
wealthy Beyond imagination the company's
annual revenue quadrupled from 108
billion in 2011 to 394 billion in 2022
cook made significant inroads in China
and expanded Apple Services business
despite the expansion of services and
the introduction of new products this is
still Apple's most valuable product and
we are calling it
iPhone
the iPhone still accounts for more than
half of Apple's Revenue over the years
the iPhone's camera improved and so have
its chips yet its design has remained
pretty much the same to the point that
Samsung mocked Apple in this commercial
that epic moonshot that's getting all
the likes won't be yours because this
Innovation is not coming soon to an
iPhone near you
although Apple became richer under a
cook the company has been criticized for
being slow to innovate former Apple
sales executive David sabata told the
tech News website read write technology
wise I think Tim Cook is a lightweight I
never felt passion for technology from
Tim like I did from Steve and some of
the great engineers
former Apple engineer Bob burrow told
CNBC that the dynamic has clearly and
distinctly changed
jobs was known for constantly pushing
the design team he once walked past a
prototype of an upcoming iPhone that he
didn't like and said to an engineer what
is this bleep
a remark characteristic of his candid
demeanor jobs also insisted that the
iPhone needed to be changed from plastic
to Glass even though the design team
worried that glass would crack easily
jobs insisted and told Jeff Williams
Apple's Chief Operating Officer I don't
know how we're going to do it but when
it ships in June it's going to be glass
when I've presented the initial iPad
prototypes to jobs the rectangular
designs seemed too harsh they opted to
round the edges making it easier to
slide a finger underneath and lift from
a table
job spent much of his time discussing
prototypes by the long wooden tables
outside Ives office on the other hand
cook hardly swung by the design studio
and when he did it wasn't for long cook
explained to ESPN I knew what I needed
to do was not to mimic jobs I would fail
miserably at that and I think this is
largely the case for many people who
take a baton from someone Larger than
Life you have to chart your own course
you have to be the best version of
yourself
he decided to focus on business and
operations
cook would often wake up before 4am to
review sales data he'd want to know why
certain iPhone model was outselling
another model in a given City before
becoming CEO he was Apple's Chief
Operating Officer responsible for
managing the global supply chain
he's credited with streamlining Apple's
manufacturing process which cut costs
significantly he minimized the amount of
inventory Apple held at any given time
something he learned at IBM where he was
responsible for securing components to
make PCS he once declared inventory is
fundamentally evil likening it to dairy
products he believed they should be
viewed as perishable and not be allowed
to sit around for too long
there wasn't much doubt who jobs would
pick to succeed in cook exuded calm and
listened more than he spoke I've
reportedly did not want the top job and
was more comfortable focusing on design
rather than the business side of running
a company
the only other serious Contender for CEO
was Scott Forstall the head of software
design however his ego and history of
conflicts ruled him out and then cook
pushed him out of the company after the
disastrous launch of maps that forced
all oversaw and it is beautiful the maps
were Rife with errors cook even had to
issue an apology with Forrestal God
cook-headed oversight of software
designed to Ive which put more on Ives
plate one of his big Ideas was adding
the control center that lets you swipe
from the top or bottom of the screen
Engineers originally said it couldn't be
done but I've insisted
after Jobs died there were critics who
questioned Apple's ability to innovate
so the company desperately needed a
product to wow the world and silence the
doubters
in 2012 I've arranged for Apple's top
Executives to meet at a hotel in San
Francisco to discuss a wearable device
with health sensors a noticeably absent
from the meeting was Tim Cook
he sent a message saying he had no plans
to try to fill the shoes of his
predecessor cook delegated
responsibility to Ive and to the head of
operations Jeff Williams the Apple watch
was the company's most personal product
and as a result it came with different
watch bands in various colors so people
could customize it the digital Crown to
expand and contract the app icons paid
homage to the traditional watch design
and Blended together the past and the
future cook unveiled the Apple watch in
September 2014. three years after Jobs
death it is
the next chapter in apples
story although the excitement was
palpable at the launch event the media's
reaction was lukewarm a Bloomberg
headline put it this way you'll want one
but you don't need one I've anticipated
Apple needed to make 40 million watches
in the first year to meet demand but
Apple only sold around 12 million
watches in 2015. the Apple watch did
gain traction over time and cook said it
leapfrogged Rolex to become the most
popular watch on Earth the Apple watch
sapped a lot of energy out of Vive who
had to oversee industrial design
software design and marketing all
without the collaboration of his
creative soulmate
I felt as if he had to fight hard for
his vision like convincing the marketing
team that the watch needed to be
marketed as a fashion accessory rather
than as a tech device the watch would
eventually shift from Fashion To Fitness
in an effort to boost sales
I've told the New Yorker that he'd
become deeply deeply tired and that the
year leading up to the watches debut had
been the most difficult he'd ever spent
at Apple
just like Cook's ability to squeeze more
out of suppliers the CEO appeared to be
squeezing more at a Vive who took a
three-week vacation in Hawaii to unwind
the longest break he'd had in years
Tripp mickel's book describes how I've
wanted to leave Apple which alarmed cook
who didn't want to lose the world's most
famous industrial designer
the solution was for Ive to step back
from day-to-day management and shift to
a part-time role focusing on future
projects such as designing Apple's
spaceship like headquarters two
designers who reported to him would be
given more daily responsibilities
then there was a question of what would
be Apple's Next Big Thing
launching a successful electric car
would blow away any doubt about Apple's
ability to innovate at the time Tesla
was doubling its staff and developing
more sophisticated batteries for its
electric vehicles Tesla was also
recruiting dozens of Apple engineers
jobs had reportedly shown interest in
building an Apple car as early as 2008.
Apple hired hundreds of Engineers to
start working on the secretive project
Titan I've envisioned a fully
self-driving car where passengers would
hop in and tell Siri where to take them
and off they went but as apple found out
building an autonomous car is extremely
difficult and there was no passionate
leader like jobs to spearhead things
Apple's research and development
spending in 2015 hit 8 billion with the
secretive car project undoubtedly eating
up a huge chunk of that budget reliable
Apple analyst Ming Chi kuo believes it's
unlikely an Apple car will hit the
market before 2025.
Apple then turned its attention to
another product wireless earbuds would
further free people from their iPhone as
the Apple watch had done Ives design
team had brainstormed the idea of
airpods back in 2013. when they first
came out people thought they looked a
little ridiculous
comedian Conan O'Ryan poked fun at their
potential for falling out of people's
ears despite the issues the airpods
quickly gained popularity for their
sound quality and seamless integration
with the Apple ecosystem yet it was
clear Ives influence was diminishing he
had little to no say when cook selected
a new board member to replace a longtime
Confidant of his Mickey Drexler cook
named James Bell Boeing's former Chief
Financial Officer to Apple's board which
addressed a lack of diversity I've
supported diversifying the board but
preferred someone with marketing
expertise over Finance mickel's book
reports a colleague defending The Pick
of bell told Ive he's an
underrepresented minority he has a great
reputation I've reportedly responded who
cares we have to be concerned about the
company he's another one of those
accountants
the appointment could be seen as
demonstrating Cook's political adeptness
he was Apple's Chief Diplomat he Charmed
the pants off Chinese ministers to
secure government approval needed to use
the iPhone on the country's largest
wireless carrier he navigated in an
environment in which president Trump
vowed to bring jobs back to America
which was worrying for a company that
benefited from China's cheap labor cook
had masterminded the Outsourcing of
Apple's production to China through the
Taiwanese company Foxconn
there was significant controversy after
a Spate of suicides in the 2000s and
2010s tied to brutal working conditions
in Foxconn factories Nets were installed
to catch people as they fell Apple has
taken steps to address the working
conditions including conducting regular
Audits and inspections
85 percent of Apple's Pro lineup of
iPhones is reportedly made in iPhone
City a sprawling campus in jinju China
that employs as many as 300 000 people
depending heavily on China hurt apple as
covid restrictions delayed iPhone
shipments Apple realized it had to
diversify and is now trying to open up
iPhone cities in India and Vietnam
cook also had to manage many issues
unrelated to product development like
the time the FBI demanded Apple unlock
an iPhone used by one of the shooters in
the San Bernardino attack in 2015. apple
resisted citing user privacy concerns
the FBI managed to access the data
through the help of a third party and in
2020 fortnite Creator epic games sued
Apple accusing it of anti-competitive
practices Apple had removed fortnite
from the app store after epic games
allowed in-app purchases in fortnite
bypassing Apple's 30 Commission
so while Tim Cook was very busy he spent
little time coming up with Apple's next
big product instead Apple made changes
to its existing lineup like removing the
home button from the iPhone 10. but the
iPhone 10 was also delayed due to issues
with a facial recognition system let's
try that again
ho ho ho
Let's uh go to backup here the delays
coincided with Ive not being in the
office every day
according to mickel's book he moved some
meetings off campus to a private club in
San Francisco which apparently irked
some apple Executives they were also
reportedly not happy that Ive was
believed to be getting paid much more
than that each member of the executive
team earned about 25 million dollars
annually which was publicly disclosed to
comply with the sec's requirements
however I've avoided being classified as
an officer and as a result his
compensation was Kept Secret
some senior Apple employees felt the
best days were behind them when top
software designer Imran Chaudhary
prepared to leave the company in 2016.
he sent a farewell email and quoted the
poet Rumi when you do things from your
soul you feel a river moving in you a
joy he then played off that line by
writing sadly Rivers dry out and when
they do you look for a new one
the comments infuriated management
including Ive and chaudry was fired
another employee who left Chris Stringer
was a top designer who was unhappy with
Apple's smart speaker
he believed Apple treated the homepod
like an afterthought rather than a
signature product the homepod has lagged
far behind the popularity of Amazon's
Echo and Google's Nest I've realized how
much his team struggled without him and
decided to return to a more Hands-On
role in late 2017. yet it was never the
same again
the successors to the iPhone 10 looked
almost identical
cook had hoped the lower quality XR
would do well in China but it bombed
partly due to competition from Huawei in
January 2019 Apple lowered Revenue
guidance to 84 billion instead of the 89
to 93 billion it had previously
projected cook blamed the economy and
trade sanctions but the reality was
people were also getting tired of only
incremental changes to the iPhone Apple
noticed customers who usually upgraded
their phones every two years were not
doing so nearly as often despite the
challenges Apple had a milestone to look
forward to that year in 2019 as it
prepared to celebrate the formal opening
of its new headquarters in May
however a day before Ives dad had a
stroke he rushed to the UK to be with
his father who thankfully recovered
Johnny owed his career to his father who
had taught design at UK schools and
nurtured his interest in design
for Johnny it was time to consider
returning to the UK for good with his
wife and twin boys
a month later in June 2019 I've gathered
a group of his designers and told them
he was leaving Apple
he explained he'd grown tired of the
company's bureaucracy Mickel writes in
his book that I've told the team I don't
want to go to any more bleeping meetings
the design team would now report to the
Chief Operating Officer Jeff Williams
Ives foot wasn't fully at the door
however he set up his own design firm
alongside Mark Newson an influential
designer at Apple who worked under his
guidance their firm love from would
consult for Apple the contract was
reportedly worth a hundred million
dollars
although I've hoped the relationship
between his firm and apple would last
for quote many many years to come as he
told the financial times that would not
be the case in 2022 apple and Ive parted
ways for good
Steve Jobs was well aware that great
companies faltered after their Founders
departed it happened to Disney after the
absence of Walt's leadership and a Sony
when co-founder Akio Morita stepped down
as chairman
jobs told his biographer Walter Isaacson
the company does a great job innovates
and becomes a monopoly or close to it in
some field and then the quality of the
product becomes less important the
company starts valuing the great
salesman because they're the ones who
can move the needle on revenues not the
product engineers and designers so the
sales people end up running the company
has his worst fear come true
[Music]
when working on stories like these that
take a significant amount of research I
know how important it is to get a good
night's sleep so I stay sharp and
productive I've noticed my sleep has
gotten better since I've been
supplementing with magnesium which I've
been taking for about a year now I had
no idea that 75 percent of people are
magnesium deficient which can lead to
higher levels of anxiety irritability
low energy and trouble sleeping
magnesium is involved in more than 300
chemical processes inside your body so a
lot of different things can start to go
wrong if you're deficient it's also
important to get the right kind of
magnesium I recommend magnesium
Breakthrough by by optimizers it's the
only organic full spectrum magnesium
supplement that includes seven unique
forms of magnesium visit
megbreakthrough.com newsthink in order
now and in addition to the 10 discount
you get by using my promo code news
think 10 there are always amazing gifts
with purchase the link is in my
description
thanks for watching I'm Cindy Palm
foreign